want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only will smith
so i do uh screamed to me the other
night hey will i want to be an actor man
i want to be an actor just like you you
know usually people say stuff to me like
that i'm like yeah man you know you do
is give them an encouraging word but i
was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99
of people that say stuff like that are
not willing to do what it takes to make
their dreams come true the marines have
a saying everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die
and that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline
you know some something as simple as
food and eating
it's not about your your body as much as
it is about your mind it's getting
command of your mind to be able to
choose actions that are in your own best
interest every day
we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you and the
world's trying to hold you down so you
gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world
if you can't win the war against your
own mind the being prepared
for the next thing is so
wildly critical um
i think life in general is rise and fall
everything is rise and fall and there's
been a couple times in my life where i
got caught um
holding on to
the last wave while it's
while it's dying oh i have a good quote
for that yeah i have a casey neistat
quote which is like that i don't even he
probably didn't make this up but tarzan
can't get to the next branch if he
hasn't looked yes absolutely that's
that's the same philosophy yep
absolutely and you've got to be when
you're grabbing that first one and
you're holding it it's going to be there
it's fantastic but you got to
know
that you're gonna have to let go at some
point because the same thing that saved
your life if you hang on it'll kill you
there was a real period in my life that
i had to to struggle
with
we can win
or i can be nice
pick one
right and
different people pick different things
right
for the type of
material world climbing
you know that that i did for a big chunk
of
my life
um
it was military-minded
you know we're going to get that flag to
the top of that hill
and you are going to help or you're not
going to be here right so that's that's
one mindset
and then after i got the flag to the
hill a couple of times and kept getting
the flag to the hill
and realized that
you just
you don't feel good
and you've
scorched earth
you know around you and
you're like no but nobody's really happy
you know and then i started to have to
question
that mindset you know i had one of the
greatest runs
in hollywood history
you know that eight number one movies
all over a hundred domestic biggest
global movie star all of that and my
family was miserable
you know
and i had equated winning
with
happiness
right it's like we're winning what is
your problem you know
you know and
the the transition
from product focus
like
military-minded get to the top of that
hill
and then i shifted into
a mindset it was really my kids who
brought me
out of that i
shift into discovering
like well damn people really
care about how they feel
right
you know yeah and it's as crazy as that
sound like you know you know my my
father
wasn't concerned with how i felt
you know he wasn't concerned with how he
felt
he was military minded you achieved the
mission
and there's two possibilities when i
give you a mission there's two
possibilities one you complete the
mission or two you're dead
right
you know that's what my father was
saying i grew up with that oh cool right
i actually had to discover
feelings
right and start like i used to have to
really focus
okay how's this person feel how's this
person feel not what do i need them to
do and not they're wasting our time
right now and we're losing time and
we're going to not finish this mission
right but there's a there is a balance
between the mindset of achieving
and
loving kindness
that
at this point in my life i've actually
discovered the magical balance but it's
really hard to get people to let go
of the attack and defend
achievement mindset
and trust
the care and concern
for
your fellow humans as a way of creating
higher production for my career
my my whole
approach
to
building an image
and to
building something
that young black kids and kids around
the world could aspire to
one of the major aspects of that
is i was strictly only creating images
that were of the highest intelligence
the highest power i needed to be as high
and fly as high
as i could possibly fly so young black
kids would see
that kind of flying and really all kids
could see that type of flying
as not something that only white movie
stars could do for me and
for for what my role is in the community
uh the reason i chose emancipation now
is
more than ever we have to
understand the reality of where we came
from yeah the problem is there's an
absence of knowledge about the history
it's really difficult to elevate without
the knowledge and wisdom being presented
in a way that the youth among us in
their most powerful form are also
educated it's like reforming
policing
everybody agrees i grew up with violence
in my home
you know so
um
i developed you know a really acute
emotional sense
you know out of defense you know i just
needed to make sure that my father was
okay i needed to make sure things were
going well and i just became really
hypersensitive
um
to emotional
movement in a room as a as a defense
mechanism and then as i
you know grew and as i started to
uh
develop that you know that heightened
sense that started out as defense as i
settled down and you know came into uh
a deeper understanding of my my
uh
my power and my desires in the world
it was easier
to connect to people
in a loving way it trans it transferred
easily from a defense mechanism to an
ability to love
and and care for people our childhood
experiences
form our adult desires absolutely and i
feel like now people are starting to
hear that in the conversation where
they're like oh yeah because this
happened with my parents
now i feel like this
how do you think you were able to
because we've talked about this before
when you've talked about different
your mother your father what you learned
from them tell us a bit about
what you learned and how you were able
to process it positively and engage with
it rather than create a negative story
from it because a lot of people may see
violence and react differently yeah yeah
i think there's always
uh an aspect of us
that when we feel unloved
you know in any capacity in any
relationship when we feel unloved
when we feel mistreated
when we feel
somehow disrespected
it's a natural reaction to want revenge
and i think that's what happens with
most people specifically in our in our
most vulnerable stages when we're
children
and we haven't done anything to deserve
that kind of treatment um it's really
hard for the ego to not click into
revenge
you know
and
you know once i discovered that that
mechanism once i saw that that
like that that most of us walk around
with yeah that you know we we want
revenge
against that mistreatment
it's a little piece of that with all of
us
so the problem is that
when you seek revenge you destroy
yourself
and that's the
um
that's the
paradoxical
conflict
that we all live in someone has
mistreated us
we want revenge but if we take it we
hurt ourselves more
it's crazy right you know what i mean
you know so that is the uh as rather not
swami referred to the perplexing
situation that we find ourselves in
and
the the the only
answer
is loving kindness and
most of us don't want to hear that it's
like
i'll take my chances with revenge
[Laughter]
i'm going to take my chances with
punching this dude in the face or
cussing this girl out or whatever it
takes but uh um i can't do love and
kindness
and for me i had such a beautiful
example of loving kindness in my
grandmother
when when i was growing up i always knew
i wanted to be that
the way that she loved and cared for
people um i didn't realize that her
giving was connected to her piece
that was something that that i got a
concept of
later but i always knew that that was my
example and i think that's the critical
part we need we need an example somebody
has to be an example human beings are
uh creatures of example we need we you
got to see it yeah you know so
uh
that's really where i am
in my life right now
i i want to
show what it looks like
to be loving and kind
and giving
and forgiving
and i just want to i want to model
those virtues as best i can one of the
the beautiful parts of social media that
i think is a beautiful evolutionary
thing is that social media demands
uh
authenticity right so social media
pushes you more and more
into
having to
reveal
what's true and because if you don't you
know tmz is going to right
you know so it's um you know it's a
beautiful thing i'm and i'm actually
enjoying the push right nobody's happy
who doesn't get to beat himself
right so the the the eyes and ears of
the world are starting to demand more
and more authenticity where you gotta
say what's true for you and live or die
by what that is so i'm enjoying the uh
the social demand for authenticity and
when you when you look at
um the
athletes
right there's a certain extreme mindset
that
you
i was gonna say you have to take on i
don't know that you have to take it on
what i do know is that in this society
um
we worship that mindset
that um
you know it's the the can you become
michael jordan
without that mindset yeah
you know and
that is a that is a really
powerful
difficult question it's like
most people can't sustain the mindset
yes
that you know fortunately because it's
it can be so destructive but most people
can't sustain
that level of discipline to manifest the
things that they want in in their life
and
there's just a
there's a poisonous edge
to
that kind of discipline and i've been to
the edge of that kind of material world
discipline in my mind and i can tell you
you can have a whole lot of stuff and be
miserable out there
on that edge and i found a much more
comfortable
uh and productive space in my life and
you still need that discipline yes but
it it it's like when you're when you use
that kind of power to achieve things
it's like there's a uh
there's a there's a uh
brutal reckoning yeah
there's a brutal reckoning at the at the
end of that for me is
laughing is the elixir you know and that
was another thing that my father taught
me he was he was joking
all the way up to the end like laughing
you have to be able to laugh at
everything and for me the beautiful
part is uh that that's my natural
um
uh color on the spectrum i naturally go
to comedy you know and when when when
i'm looking at something i'm always
trying to find why that's funny when we
move through the world
you are confronting defiled
and degraded minds
and it's never going to be any different
than that it's the way
god designed this place you are going to
come across people that have made
poisonous conclusions
and
false beliefs
and and they've they've got
insane narratives running through their
minds and as you walk through the street
you're coming in contact with that all
day long
so
in trying to
build systems because that's what's
going to happen now we're going to build
new systems right
and in building our new systems
you're still going to be confronting
those same defiled and degraded minds in
these circumstances the problem
isn't completely in the system the
problem is in the hearts and minds of
people it demands that our attention
begin on our hearts and minds as a
country i would hope that a part of what
we're learning right now
is the destructive
aspects of loveless
godless leadership don't succumb to
lovelessness no matter how much evil you
face because you poison yourself and you
poison your own community when you
succumb to lovelessness to be in a
position to
at that age to start tasting your dreams
um
and
yeah
it's double edge it was it was a
double-edged sword at that at that time
but
the i got my first
thousand dollars
at 17 years old wow and they handed me
10
uh 100 bills
for
rapid
and like it was it was it was crazy and
i knew that i was never ever going to do
anything that would stop somebody from
handing me 10 100 bills
you know
and you know it's like word up records
or this yeah that was word up yeah that
was like a thousand dollars right so
and you know it was it was helpful for
me in the sense that it immediately
curbed my vices
like i was i was you know 22 years old
be before i took a drink i've never
smoked weed i haven't done drugs like i
was like i i was i so
enjoyed getting a thousand dollars that
it it it knocked out you know everything
other than uh
my i i love women so that was that was
the only thing in my life that i that
that i struggled with but and the sun
was girls ain't nothing but trouble so
yeah right
exactly
uh but it really just it really knocked
out that it knocked out uh a lot of the
potential vices
that that i could have fallen into the
thing is um
and you know when i when i started i had
you know all these grand ambitions of
what i wanted to be and what i wanted to
do and you know i want to be the biggest
movie star in the world um so i studied
that and i worked out and i got my body
crazy and i did you know just got my
head around um doing everything i could
do to be the biggest movie star in the
world you know and then i had a taste of
that
and
i realized that even though i had
achieved all those things
on the inside i was still that same
insecure little boy that was trying to
prove something
you know to
to you know girls that had cheated and
to my father and all of that and that
you can't achieve your way out of
your
you know childhood wounds and traumas
you can't fake it you can't fake it
right so then i made the shift and what
i realized is that the only sustainable
mission
um
throughout your whole uh existence is to
improve lives and as soon as i made the
shift in my mind from trying to be big
and trying to have money and trying to
be popular to making sure that i
improved lives every step of the way on
this earth then all of a sudden i
started experiencing healing you know
and alfonso was one of those people that
was right there with me making that
transition from product and winning to
love and people it's like everybody was
sitting at home
looking at their devices
right when what felt like a new atrocity
to some people
but was happening over and over again
for african americans and for this to
happen in this time for the whole world
to see
what we've been saying
for hundreds of years yes my grandmother
taught me to
try to be thankful
for these times and these opportunities
to try to be thankful for your pain you
know and
we are in a circumstance that we've
never been before the entire globe
has stood up and said to the
african-american
people we see you and we hear you how
can we help we've never been there
before it's funny i learned a really
valuable lesson in this right because
the
um
the
the network wanted to do one more season
of the fresh prince
and
i remember i was considering i was going
to do one more season of the fresh
prince and we had we've done an episode
of something with john amos
and john amos came to me said hey man
listen
he's like don't overstay your welcome
on on tv he was like
you're doing great stuff he's like
you do not want to get cancelled in the
middle of a season it's like go out on
your terms the way that you want to go
out be able to say goodbye to your fans
don't get caught okay yeah that's good
advice so this was the sixth season and
i had an opportunity to do one more
season but i was feeling like the
quality wasn't necessarily
going to stay up and i decided to to end
the show in the in the sixth season
you're like the prince but now you're
the king of instagram i know right now
so it's like how come you've embraced
social media in this way like because
for the longest you know you have this
mystique behind you well in you know
when i when i started the the
the only way to be a movie star was
through
uh distance and mystery and mystique
right that was the the the way is that
you know
yeah you could see me on july 4th in the
movie theater or you're not going to see
me right so that was the way keeping
that distance was how you maintained
star power and in the last five years
that shifted uh much more to
a friendship model like people support
um artists that they feel like they know
thoroughly that they're friends right so
that the social media the the daily
interaction is much more like a family
friendship kind of interaction that is
an audience demand
for
uh for
you know their loyalty
but is there such thing as revealing too
much
um not in this world um too much that
that's it's personal you know like it's
it's
what can you handle you know i think one
of the major um
one of the the beautiful parts of social
media that i think is a beautiful
evolutionary thing is that social media
demands
uh
authenticity right so social media
pushes you more and more
into
having to
reveal
what's true and because if you don't you
know tmz is going to right
you know so it's um you know it's a
beautiful thing i'm and i'm actually
enjoying the push right nobody's happy
who doesn't get to beat himself right so
the the the eyes and ears of the world
are starting to demand more and more
authenticity where you got to say what's
true for you and live or die by what
that is so i'm enjoying the uh the
social demand for authenticity i'm
coming into a space how have you
maintained your authenticity because i
mean you come from philly you've gone
through everything like your journey's
been crazy like how have you maintained
that
um
you know what's really interesting is
it's like
the the idea i i i haven't maintained
my authenticity per se
i've maintained
my
character
right i've maintained
um
my
beliefs character in two senses i've
maintained my character of will smith
and i've maintained my personal
character of what i believe in
so but in terms of authenticity
um
the character
will smith signs every autograph and is
always happy and wants to see the fans
and is always in a good mood and that's
actually not often authentic
right i actually i do want to slap some
somebody you know
every once in a while so in terms of
authenticity i i have successfully
maintained positivity
and now i'm working more to maintain
authenticity i'm granting myself the
freedom to not give when i don't give up
yeah right and now i'm working into a
space of much more
uh authenticity is it okay to punch
sharks in the face you're like back up
with your shark ass
back up with your shark ass
shuck ass back up
shock jab shock jab yeah
i got it
[Applause]
the question isn't can you handle the
situation
the question is can you handle your mind
can you manage the thoughts and the
emotions that are trying to poison your
progress
forget managing the situation
manage your mind
training your mind
to sit calmly
in the eye of the storm
can you talk about advice that you're
happy you didn't take
at some point in your careers oh man
yeah this one yeah
sorry mom
um
um
one of the most critical
uh for me and and um
you know it was uh it was 1986.
um
and girls ain't nothing but trouble came
out in in june so i had a i had a record
out a month before i graduated from high
school
right so first song it was that pretty
much just in philly and and you know
dc jersey it hadn't expanded yet um but
it was time for me to start applying to
college
and um
and you know my mother is a
serious uh
you know educational disciplinarian it's
like education was everything for her
and she could tell that i was kind of
feeling like maybe i didn't want to go
to college
and you know she told me that you know
if i didn't go
to college
that i was throwing my life away
and and it's like i i understood what
she was saying but that that just wasn't
true for me you know that wasn't true
for me at the time and i wanted to take
a shot at my art i wanted to take a shot
at the music and you know so
my my father convinced my mother that i
would have a year they would give me a
year where i would be able to pursue
the the music and then if in a year i
hadn't made anything happen that that i
would go back to to college um and in
that year uh we were nominated and we
won the first grammy ever given
i'm always trying to create something
that people are going to remember you
know um it's you know for me
movies are about ideas and you can have
all the action you want and you know you
can have great chemistry and you can
have
all of those elements but the important
thing is like what are you saying when
you get to the end of a movie it's like
people will be like okay why did i just
give two hours of my life you know my
life and my money right
yeah you know why did i do that and to
me it's really incred it's really
critical to be saying something you know
and at the core of this bad boys movie
sort of the the the the premise of what
we're talking about is grow or die
right and it's like you you you have to
stay committed to growing you have to
stay committed to
finding the next phase and the next
chapter of your life if you cling to a
dead thing you're going to die along
with it for me when i look at
hollywood you know hollywood is an
interesting microcosm of the world you
know and it's like the the reality is
any human being that has a power
position they're gonna look out for
themselves
and you can't begrudge somebody that you
know
it's like people are fearful and people
are desirous of things for themselves
so when people have a a power base you
know
like you take care of yourself and you
take care of your own you know so the
the question becomes how can we share
right and it's and it's always going to
be difficult for somebody when sharing
means they have to have less
for you if sharing means you're going to
get more sharing is a good thing
but when you asking somebody to share
and you know they're going to have less
that's i mean that's that's that's
difficult you got to expect there's
going to be um
you're trying to appeal to people's
deeper human
um kindness and their altruism and it
it's really difficult to do that if
you're gonna snatch it and grab it away
from them you see it with kids all the
time share with your friends like mom if
you're snatching it from them telling
them to share with their friends that's
not gonna really that's not gonna go
well right so for me jada and i debate
all the time on the way that you you
have to open people up to uh
sharing um things that they've either
acquired uh gracefully or stolen either
way they get them they consider them
theirs no no we're not just bungee
jumping on a helicopter we're gonna do
it at the grand canyon
and when i was up there and and i jumped
i realized you know it's fun and it's
exciting and
there's something
mythological about confronting
death right because as much as we're
laughing and as much as we're having fun
it really is the emotional
confront with death you know and i'm 50
years old now and i'm sort of having the
realization that you you you have to be
able
to go
you have to be able to take that shot at
the thing that you dream you have to be
able to take that shot at that that love
that you want and that life that you
want to build and it's like you know
when i was up there and the guy said to
me the only way you can get hurt is if
you don't get away from the chopper
right and he said in that moment he said
we're going to let the courts go and
these cords weigh 200 pounds
right so when we let them go
they're gone
the hesitation is the thing that really
messes up the chance at having your
dreams right
get out of the
middle but the moment of pushing off is
pure freaking terror
and then there's the moment of falling
but you're gone so it's really nothing
you can do
that
and just like life there's nothing to
hold on to
and we're all trying to hold on to
something you're trying to hold on to an
idea or you're trying to hold on to a
person and there's nothing to hold on to
and we gotta just get comfortable
falling
knowing
there's nothing to hit right you know
and that's the idea it's like
life is dangerous
and the only way to really enjoy it is
jump and be free so you challenge
yourself a lot of times i remember
there's even one rap you was like i did
i dare rapper to write a verse without a
curse yeah so what is it now you think
you've loosened up kind of on this dance
more like you don't mind yeah you know
for me it's um
it's
it's much more about authenticity one of
the major things was the idea of duality
right the idea that
right and wrong aren't separate things
they're together
right so
something that happens to you is the
best thing and the worst thing that
happens to you you can't you can't
separate them like they go together
everything has it's yin and it's yang
and you can't get around it so the idea
that my grandmother teaching me
um about profanity during that time was
what worked to help elevate my
um
career and it helped elevate my
experiences but it's not necessarily
right to not curse
you
you curse when it's the right thing not
gratuitously not true right you you know
it's like
when it makes your point
like talent telling somebody to shut
at the right time is the right thing you
scared me right
[Laughter]
you know what i mean so it's like
um giving myself rather than specific
hard and fast rules and paradigms now
i'm trying to feel the universe and feel
the moments and feel the opportunities
for what is right for me in this moment
so me and jada was
reflecting about
love
and i asked her i said what did she
think was
you know one of the biggest revelations
that
she had had about love
she said that
you cannot
make a person happy
and i thought that was a real deep idea
you can make a person smile you can make
a person feel good you can make a person
laugh but whether or not a person is
happy is deeply and totally and utterly
out of your control
i remember the day
i retired
i literally said to jada that's it
i retire i retire from trying to make
you happy
i need you to go make yourself happy and
just prove to me that it's even possible
and after we cracked the hell up
um
we started talking about we came into
this
false
romantic
concept that
somehow when we got married that we
would become one
and what we realized is that
we were two completely separate people
on two completely separate individual
journeys
and that we were choosing to walk our
separate journeys together
but her happiness was her responsibility
and my happiness was my responsibility
and we decided that we were going to
find our individual
uh
internal private separate joy
and then we were going to present
ourselves to the relationship and to
each other already happy
not coming to each other uh begging with
our empty cups out uh demanding that she
fill my cups in the cup and demanding
that she meet my needs unfair and is
it's kind of unrealistic
and
can be
destructive to
place the responsibility for your
happiness on anybody other than yourself
taking responsibility accepting
responsibility is not an admission of
guilt
you're not you're not admitting that
you're
at fault taking responsibility is a
recognition of the power that you seize
when you stop blaming people it's not
like you're letting somebody who wronged
you off the hook like taking
responsibility is an act of emotional
self-defense taking responsibility is
taking your power back
you know for me it comes down to
you know after you get beyond the rage
rage is is justified under oppression it
also can be really dangerous you got to
be careful not to be consumed by your
own rage
yeah you know and that's something that
i've worked really hard on and what i
loved about the peaceful protest it's
like peaceful protests put up a mirror
to the demonic imagery of your oppressor
and the more still you are in your
peaceful protest the more clear
the mirror is
to
the oppressor
for the world to see and for them to see
themselves
you know so i was really encouraged by
how powerfully this generation
was able to hold that mirror you
differentiate though between talent and
hard work absolutely
i've never really viewed myself as
particularly talented i view myself as
you know slightly above average in
talent where i excel is ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guy's sleeping i'm working while
the other guy's eating i'm working while
the other guy's making love well i mean
i'm making love too but i'm working
really hard at it working really hard
so when the phone rings and you have an
alarm goes off since denzel washington
right now is hooking up you got to go
right now right
you know for me man it's like the the
separation of talent and skill is one of
the the the greatest misunderstood
concepts for people who are trying to
excel who have dreams that want to do
things talent you have naturally skill
is only developed by hours and hours and
hours of beating on your craft and you
know for me it's i feel like i have a
relationship with the audience they
agree that they're gonna go in droves
and i agree that every time they go it's
going to be better than the last time so
i think that's part of the the the
relationship and i'm going to hold up my
part as long as they keep holding up
there
it gets more and more difficult i used
to be able to to
eat whatever i want and then in six
weeks i could get in any shape i wanted
to get into but that's not the case
anymore we're we're around the 12 or 14
week uh
mandatory uh training to to do anything
but but i love it i'm i enjoy
um
i enjoy the discipline of it for me
working on
on your body is the beginning of
everything you know your mind starts to
work better you're
the better husband a better father a
better friend and life is just
better when you you know care for your
body at the highest level you told the
famous story about how you kind of
backed into acting fresh prince of
bel-air yeah and the next thing you know
you start making these movies and i
forget that bad boys actually came
before independence day right yeah yeah
independence day just was like one of
the biggest of all time like what was
that transition like for you yeah a real
actor and like the biggest actor in the
game no it was um
that was like the first real
um goal
like that in terms of setting goals i
was like i want to be the biggest movie
star in the world
right and every up until that point
everything was like it was fun and it
was happening and we were creating in
jeff's mom's basement and it was
successful but that was like when i
moved into acting that was the first
time i started uh applying
uh
skill to
my my talents right and you know i
always look i look at skill and talent
separately like p you're born with
talent you know it's like there's
certain things that you just do
naturally you were gifted with a talent
and you have it um but skill is acquired
through
discipline and
you know i've never seen myself as
particularly talented where i excel is
i'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill
like it's
you know when i put my obsessive mind on
something
i'm just not yeah right exactly exactly
it's not not working i said you also
said ridiculous and sickening work
sickening work epic exactly it's like
you know so for me to be a movie star
was the first thing that i ever really
wanted like that and set my eye on he
was like what's the vegas stallone
all of them i was like
i was like you know because when i when
i looked i always felt like there
weren't a lot of people i saw
do things that i felt like i couldn't do
right when i when i look at people and i
see things um i don't i don't feel like
i can't
whether or not i will is something
different but i don't ever feel like i
can't any time i anytime i put something
in the world i
i'm always connecting to an idea i'm
always asking why am i making this
what why so i'm putting this out in the
world
why so with with concussion dr benedo
malu was deeply connected to tell the
truth
and he said that truth doesn't have a
side and that's what he kept saying i
thought that was such a powerful idea
that they're
you know whose side are you on you're
republican or democrat i'm i'm just i'm
trying to tell the truth
true the truth doesn't have a side i
think the the important thing is there
there's there's one relationship that
you have to maintain and that's the one
with you
right and it's like if if you're not
loving you if you're not taking care of
you everything and everybody is second
to you taking care of you can you come
back tomorrow
you need to let that breathe
and
when when you have bad relationships and
and when things go wrong which they
which they always will
it's like you know me and jay to be
going at it me and me and my kids you
know there's heavy debates around things
a lot but first and foremost when you
are steady and calm in yourself it makes
it easier to manage the insanity that
other people are going to bring to you
because like as soon as somebody else is
off the hook if you respond to off the
hook with off the hook the
relationship's done yeah you know so
it's like taking taking care of you
centering yourself the airline's got it
right put your mask on first before
attempting to assist others skydiving is
a really interesting confront with fear
[Applause]
you go out the night before and you you
know you take a drink with your friends
and somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow and you go yeah we'll
go skydiving more yes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
right you're like well i mean they was
drunk too
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep
and you're terrified you keep imagining
over and over again jumping out of an
airplane and you can't figure out why
you would do that
so you get there and then you have the
safety brief and you're standing there
and the guys will tell you well if the
shoot doesn't open what's going to
happen is you're doing you well why the
hell what could happen
so you get onto the airplane and you're
sitting there and and you know it's
extra because you're sitting on some
dude's lap some stranger
to make small talk yeah man you know
so you you be jumping with people all
the time huh
so you fly and you go up to 14 000 feet
and somebody opens the door
and in that moment you realize you've
never been in a freaking airplane with
the door open
terror terror terror terror
and then people start going out of the
airplane
and the guy
walks you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death
[Music]
they say on three
[Music]
one
two and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three
[Music]
and you fall out of the airplane
[Music]
and in one second
you realize
that it's the most blissful experience
of your life you're flying
[Music]
there's zero fear you realize that the
point of maximum danger is the point of
minimum
fear
[Music]
the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before what
do you need that fear for
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
and then in that moment all of a sudden
where you should be terrified is the
most blissful experience of your life
and god placed the best things in life
on the other side of fear greatness is
not this
wonderful esoteric elusive
uh
god-like
feature that
only the special among us uh will ever
taste you know it's something that truly
exists
in
all of us it's very
simple
this is what i believe
and i'm willing to die for it yeah
period
it's that simple i know who i am i don't
know what i believe i know who i am i
know who what i've all i need to know
that's all i need to know so from there
you do what you need to do
you know and i think what happens is we
make this situation more complex than it
has to be because we're looking for
complexity it's got to be something
complex to understand right can't be
that easy i gotten probably two weeks
into
my preparation for the film and my
father was diagnosed with cancer so we
just started talking about love time
and death and we we it was some of the
most open and powerful conversations
that
we you know we we'd ever had and um they
they gave him six weeks
and
uh he actually he lived for four months
so about three months into the six weeks
you know i go to see him one day and he
said man this is embarrassing
and i said what daddy said man you tell
everybody you gonna be dead in six weeks
three months later you still hanging
around
laughing is the elixir you know and that
was another thing that my father taught
me he was he was joking all the way up
to the end like laughing
you have to be able to laugh at
everything and for me the beautiful part
is uh that that's my natural
um
uh color on the spectrum i naturally go
to comedy you know and when when when
i'm looking at something i'm always
trying to find why that's funny and you
know it's been really really helpful
in in this experience and and you know
even just uh this point in my life keep
remember to laugh remember to laugh and
and spend time with people that make you
laugh like that is hugely important as a
child my parents always told me you
could be whatever you want to be you
could do whatever you want to do
and
you know that that office that position
the highest office on the face of the
earth
it was something i heard my parents
saying it but i didn't totally believe
it yet i went out in the world and i
carried myself and i held my head high
and i stood there and i looked people in
their eyes and i talk to people as if i
was deserving of everything that this
planet has to offer
so i just i really want to say to to
children out there and to to people who
are watching confucius said one time
he who says he can and he who says he
can't are both usually right
so i want to stand here before you
and as i hold this award i want to give
love to my wife and i want you to keep
in your heart just know that you can
know that you can
and the greatest thing in my in my
career has been
the constant commitment to putting
something in the world of value
not putting something in the world that
makes me look hot
you know yeah um so i think as long as
you can stay focused on delivering your
art and delivering yourself and
delivering your energy and delivering
your ideas
for the world to be better the
separation of talent and skill is one of
the the the greatest misunderstood
concepts for people who are trying to
excel who have dreams that want to do
things talent you have naturally skill
is only developed by hours and hours and
hours of beating on your craft there's
no easy way around it no matter how
talented you are your talent is going to
fail you if you're not skilled you know
if you don't study if you don't work uh
really hard and dedicate yourself to
being better every single day you'll
never be able to communicate with with
people you know i think my my dreams
over the past you know a couple of
decades have been
like you know physical dreams i wanted
to accomplish things you know i want to
be the biggest movie star in the world
and yeah
you know so it was all success-oriented
and i think now
um
if you look at it away like going up the
mountain i was acquiring right and i
guess as i come down on the other side
now i want to give it away
right so sort of the the
the dreams that i have is i i want to be
valuable like i want to be valuable to
humanity i want to you know
i haven't totally found my calling as of
yet but i want my life to be of value to
as many people and in as many ways as
possible nervous is great
it means you're outside your comfort
zone
where growth happens
did you cut your hair that looks nice
man besides you never really needed
permission to take matters into your own
hands that's jayden on his brand new
drum set
[Music]
or being courageous enough to try
something new and consistent enough to
stick to it for years even when it
knocks you down
or take challenges on way bigger than
yourself this is our first bottle of
just water you feel good about it guys
this is amazing you've always had an
interesting sense of self-expression
but you take jabs like a champ and deal
them back with effortless clouds it's
okay
i have a gut now right be honest
we never really understood your thing
with bugs though
seeing you roll around on the ground was
a lot cuter
when you were a baby
[Music]
better now that you're here
my dog you were nervous
shoot i was nervous
[Music]
[Applause]
but
we did the damn thing out there
[Applause]
living tequila then we make some icon
chill he was raised in an icon village
where cars get raised
[Music]
when i started in in entertainment
um
the
lack of tech
was
a massive creative hindrance
right it was
um you could have an idea
and it literally could take you a month
before you could get the resources
together to get the idea out of your
mind onto something you could listen to
right with music okay um and
with film it was impossible if you had
if you had images in your mind you know
and with a super eight camera to try to
shoot something and then try to sync it
was literally impossible so two things
happened with that so with one with rap
music what happened was only the best of
the best got through
right so 1986 the summer that uh me and
jeff released our
first album if i named all the rappers
you would know who they were cause you
you jazzy jeff and fresh prince heavy d
eric beer rock kim public enemy it's
like you did you couldn't get through
yeah so then what happens with
technology as soon as technology gets
democratized then everybody can do it
and now more things
get out and there's a lesser
quality
to the things that make it to to the
world so i would say uh technology is an
absolute um
necessity to advance human imagination
so i was thinking about um
love
i was thinking about how difficult it is
for us to find and to
to maintain
the love that we all yearn for
and it it kind of dawned on me that i
think a big part of the problem is that
we misdefine love
[Music]
it's possible that no other one subject
has been more analyzed talked about and
experienced by every single person on
this planet than love and yet
we really have
no clue what it is
so me and jada was reflecting
[Music]
about
love
you cannot
make a person happy you can make a
person smile you can make a person feel
good you can make a person laugh
but whether or not a person is happy is
deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control the thing that we call love
the thing that we're searching for and
we're trying to create that we call love
is actually not love j krishnamurti
talked about the the concept of the
desire
pleasure paradigm that we think about
love in terms of desire and pleasure
meaning that if you meet my needs
then i love you
if you don't
then i don't
so that love becomes transactional if
you do what i want if you meet my desire
and give me pleasure i love you if you
don't meet my desire and you don't give
me pleasure i don't love you i think
that that in the insatiable nature of
desire
trying to get somebody to fill our cup
i think that that leads to to anger and
it leads to
frustration and ultimately it makes us
break apart from people my daughter
willow
really taught me a hard lesson i think
that the real paradigm for love
is
gardener flower
so the relationship that a gardener has
with a flower
is the the gardener wants to flower to
be what the flower is designed to be not
what the gardener wants the flower to be
you want the flower to bloom and to
blossom and to become what it wants to
be you want it to become what god
designed it to be you're not demanding
that it become what you need it to be
for your ego anything other than all of
your gifts wide open giving and
nourishing this flower into their
greatness
is not love
life is hard right like yeah you might
get hurt
it's like
you know you you
your heart might get broken you know
it's like you might lose your job but
you still got to commit
you know
you got to commit right you know what i
mean and it's like you know you meet
somebody and you hey you know you like
her and she likes you and you're
hesitating don't hesitate go commit you
got to commit you know you might get
hurt you might lose something but it's
like you can't experience
the the joy that is intended for you in
life if you don't go you gotta go man i
think what makes a great mc is the same
thing that makes a great father makes a
great husband makes a great politician
makes a great human being and it is your
commitment to your personal
evolution your personal growth for the
purpose of assisting others
like
um
you know i'm working on this record now
called uh um it's called the mountaintop
and the the idea is i've been to the
mountaintop
right and it's like
i'm gonna do reports from the summit
right
i've been to the top of money i've i've
had all the sex that i've ever wanted
i've had all of the adulation and and
adoration and i've been to the top of
all of those material world mountains
and
nothing
makes you
happy other than being useful to others
that's it that's the only thing that
ever will satisfy
that thing is that what you are is
useful one of the favorite things i love
to do is create uh awe-inspiring
experiences that cultivate growth that
cultivate wisdom that you know elevate
uh understanding right so when i go
somewhere with my kids um i always want
to push them i just want to push the
envelope slightly and as you say you get
out of that comfort zone just a little
bit that's where your growth space is so
watching somebody uh experience wonder
and all and grow that's i just love to
do however we can build that
you had great success obviously at the
box office but you know you did your
thing on a small screen too show called
the fresh prince yeah man the team on
that show was ridiculous quincy just
he knows how to put stuff together james
avery was
uh relentlessly
on me to elevate like james avery
wouldn't give me
a damn inch
like everything i said everything i did
for james avery was like nope
not good enough you know he was like if
you you have this position
look where you are look what you are
blessed with it was like i'm sorry but
i'm not accepting anything other
than absolute
uh committed perfection from you and at
that time i was bawling you know
and james avery wouldn't give me nothing
and it's like he was he was the model
for me
of an actor
you know so the craft it's like james
avery was no
like he was so
uh like serious and like i would look at
him and and he just had that acting
power that i wanted to have
my parents drove us across country
to we were going to california for a
family reunion
so we drove
to the grand canyon and
we got there and i like i remember
having a deeply meaningful experience of
how beautiful it was but i was terrified
to walk up to the edge
and all my brothers and sisters and my
whole family walked up to the edge and i
stayed back
you know just scared to
to take in beauty
[Music]
if you're scared you're not going to
take the chances that you need to take
to to realize your dreams and that was
the thing for me i don't mind being
scared but
i'm still gonna do it i love this one
fail early fail often fail forward um
you know it's always a little bit
frustrating to me when people have a
negative relationship with failure
failure is a massive part of being able
to be
successful you have to get comfortable
with failure yeah you have to actually
seek failure failure is where all of the
lessons are you know when you go to the
gym and you work out you're actually
seeking failure you want to take your
muscles to the point where you get to
failure because that's where the the
adaptation is that's where growth is
successful people fail a lot they fail a
whole lot more than they succeed but
they extract the lessons from the
failure and they use that
the the energy and they use the wisdom
to come around to the next phase of
success you gotta take a shot you have
to live at the edge of your capabilities
you gotta live where
you're almost certain you're going to
fail that's the reason for practice
practice is controlled failure you're
getting to your limit getting to your
limit getting to your limit you can't
lift that you can't do that you until
you get to the point that all of a
sudden your body makes the adjustment
and then you can do it failure uh
actually helps you
to recognize the areas where you need to
evolve so fail early fail often fell
forward i think it was 94 or something
like that they were open to planet
hollywood i found myself in a room with
arnold schwarzenegger bruce willis and
sly and i was like oh my god i got these
three guys in the room and i was like
okay i want to be
the biggest movie star in the world and
i need you guys to tell me how to do it
and
arnold schwarzenegger he said
he said if your movie is only big in
america it doesn't matter
you'll be a movie star only when you're
a movie star in every country in the
world you have to travel you have to go
you have to meet the people thanks for
the tip facts son facts that became the
way that i started looking at movies i
wanted to be in every country in the
world in that part of my career
i refused to do anything that wasn't in
the
best interest of the goal i had set for
myself and it was probably a 12-year
period of my life where i didn't take a
drink i didn't have a drink where i
didn't go out on the weekends that i was
so set on my goal it created a serious
circle of protection and and elevation
because i refused to do anything that
wasn't in my best interest it's hugely
important that if you have a dream
that you have to dedicate your life to
it and
there every hour of every day has to be
dedicated to bring it into fruition the
things that you dream about i just saw
this roomy quote that i love set your
life on fire and seek those who fan your
flames the philly translation of that is
don't be hanging with no jank ass jokers
that don't help you shine the
prerequisite for spending time with any
person is that they nourish and inspire
you they feed your flame look at your
last five text messages are those people
feeding your flames or dousing your fire
put your phone down for just a second
and look around look to the people
around you are those people throwing
logs on your fire or are they pissing on
it the people that you spend time with
are gonna make or break your dreams
everybody don't deserve to be around you
you got to defend your light with your
life so who are the people in your life
that are fanning your flames shout them
out tag them below you know we grew up
with the sense that
where we were almost didn't matter
because
we were becoming we were becoming right
something greater what is the difference
between depression and joy
right
and
i think it's purpose right it's like
when you wake up in the morning
and
your life means something to somebody
other than you that you have a purpose
if you don't
go do the things that you're going to do
people's lives will suffer
and i think that that kind of purpose
that like to live in service not to you
but to live in service to humanity to
live in service to your family to live
in service to your church to your city
to your country to the world living in
service is that i
i feel like that is the purest form of
joy i'm motivated by fear fear you know
fear of what
fear of fear i hate
being scared to do something yeah i hate
that feeling of the feeling that i had
before i had a meeting with quincy jones
because it was really uh quincy jones
and a guy named benny medina
and jeff [ __ ] came with the idea for
the fresh prince of bel-air and
i hated
being scared you know like that i didn't
want to
even take the meeting there were there
were opportunities during
when i first
my first year as a rapper
bill cosby and and the people on the
cosby show had seen
my music video and called me to be a
character to come right and try out for
the cosby show and
just
every time it was set up for some reason
i couldn't make it
the fear of fear the fear i hated i just
hated that being scared to do something
and i think what developed uh in my in
my early days was the
the attitude that
i started attacking things
that i was scared you a better man than
me
you happy
now you're gonna tell will or not
i'm not gonna do your dirty work for you
fine
uh i'll call them from the road yeah
then why don't you do that yeah i'll do
that
daddy out
what's up
well
i'm glad you're here um
some business came up i got a handle
so we're gonna have to put a
our trip on hold
you understand
yeah yeah that's that's cool
just for a couple weeks i understand get
it
maybe a little longer yeah whatever
whatever
look i'll i'll call you next week and
we'll iron out the details okay yeah
yeah
it was great seeing you son
you too
lou
yeah
yeah um
i'm sorry will
you know what actually this works out
better for me you know this slimy's a
summer come to class wearing next to
nothing you know well it's all right to
be angry
hey why should i be mad
i'm saying at least he said goodbye this
time
i just wish i hadn't wasted my money
buying this stupid present
i'm sorry you know if there was
something that i hey you know what you
ain't going to do no nothing phil you
know ain't like i'm still five years old
you know ain't like i'm gonna be sitting
up every night asking my mom when's
daddy coming home you know who needs him
hey he wasn't there to teach me how to
shoot my first basket but i learned
didn't i hey i got pretty damn good at
it too didn't uncle phil got through my
first date without him right i learned
how to drive i learned how to shave i
learned how to fight without him i had
14
great birthdays without him he never
even sent me a damn card with him
i need him then and i don't need him now
will now you know what uncle phil i'm
gonna get through college without him
i'm gonna get a great job without him
i'ma marry me a beautiful honey and i'm
having a whole bunch of kids i'm being a
better father than he ever was and i
sure as hell don't need him for that
because ain't a damn thing he could ever
teach me about how to love my kids
how come you don't want me man
i realized that when to have the level
of success that i want to have it's
difficult to spread it out and do
multiple things you know it's in order
to
to be world class and i've made a
decision i want to be
world class and it just it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus to to excel on
a certain on the level that that i want
to make movies you know i was a star
wars when i was young i sat in a movie
theater and watched star wars and i just
couldn't believe that that movie made me
feel like that just floored and just
stunned by the creativity and just i'm
realizing that in order to move people
in that way in order to touch people in
that way you really got to focus with
all of your fiber and all your heart and
all your creativity the concept of
improving lives runs through the center
of everything i do and then i realize
that the the the way to
improve lives is to continually improve
yourself right so with that every every
morning when i when i get out of the bed
you know i
i haven't fixed everything in the world
yet so there's always something to do
and uh in this film i read an
interesting quote um
for the uh siddhartha uh gautama the
buddha he said um
that
um good people have to get out of the
bed
every day and try to empty the ocean
with a ladle
right
and i thought that was you know i knew
that was profound and i paused for a
second and i said all right what the
hell is a ladle right
right so that you know i just i touched
it on my ipad it's ladle oh it's like a
big spoon a big spoon okay it's like a
soup spoon yeah it's like a soup spoon i
was like why are you a soup spoon so try
to empty the ocean
with a soup spoon you know as the the
mentality of how you you wake up every
day to try to do good
in the world so for me i'm i'm uh i'm
really driven by continually trying to
elevate my elevate my mind and elevate
my
spirit and care for my body and um to be
able to love as many people as
effectively as as possible with this
mystery of life that i've been given
um my experience has been when people do
things for money you make bad choices
and then you'll learn how to make money
doing
what you love
when i say when i changed careers i was
never changing to something
for money i was changing to something i
loved more
right and that to me that's really the
only way to keep the passion if you have
two choices one is playing the piano
and
another one
bowling
and you can make more money bowling but
you love playing the piano more you got
to play the piano it's like you'll tear
yourself apart if you're not doing the
thing that you love most in life
and you know what it is right now
right now there's something that you
love more than everything whatever it is
that you love crazy has to be the thing
that you dedicate your life you have to
be able to be
vulnerable
in front of anybody you know you have to
be comfortable looking silly you have to
be comfortable making mistakes and you
have to break the thing inside of you
that doesn't want people to see right
because as soon as you allow people to
see all of a sudden you get access to
things that you didn't realize you had
access to right um for example like the
thing i used to do
is when i was in probably 18 or 19 years
old um i got in touch with those blocks
the camera hates emotional blocks
like you put a camera in somebody's face
and they're uncomfortable about
delivering emotion it looks fake and you
feel it you immediately know it's not
real right um especially look at the
size of this screen and in a shot that
whole screen could be just your eyes
right so it's like you can't hide
discomfort uncertainty so you have to be
able to get comfortable you know just be
in anything
anything that you have to be for the
role you have to be comfortable being
if there was one uh
concept that i would
um
suggest to people to take a daily
confrontation with is fear um
the
the the problem with fear is that it
lies
right so
fear tells you hey you know
if if you say that to that girl she's
gonna know she has you
you know and she'll never really be
attracted to you if she knows how much
you attracted to her
don't say that no how we get her is when
she walks by ignore her all right
right
you know it's like pop it on your
shoulder fear tells you dumb [ __ ] like
that right
you know
so
you know for for me the the daily
confrontation
um
with with fear has become a real
practice for me since about three three
years ago um
i went uh i went skydiving in dubai
right and skydiving skydiving is a
really interesting confront with fear
right
so so i gotta i gotta stand
stand up all right so so
all your friends what happens you go out
how are you oh sorry uh drop my thing so
what happens is you go out the night
before and you you know you take a drink
with your friends and somebody says yeah
we should go skydiving tomorrow
and you go yeah we'll go skydiving
tomorrow yeah yeah yeah and everybody
goes yeah
right and you go home but you by
yourself you're like
[Laughter]
right you're like well i mean they was
drunk too
right so so maybe maybe they not maybe
maybe i mean we don't have to go we
don't have to do it
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just
keep and you're terrified you keep
imagining over and over again jumping
out of an airplane and you can't figure
out why you would do that right and
you're laying there and you have the
worst night's sleep of your life but you
still have the hope that your friends
were drunk right
so you wake up the next day and you go
you know down and you say where you were
going to meet and everybody's there
you're like oh
um
all right all right cool cool cool cool
cool cool right so you get in the van
and you don't know that your friends had
the same night that you had because
they're pretending like they didn't
they're like yeah man my uncle's a navy
seal and you know this is gonna be great
i've been looking forward to this you
like oh my god oh my god and your
stomach is terrible you can't eat and
everything but you don't want to be the
only punk who doesn't jump out of this
airplane so you get there and then you
have the safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys will tell
you well if the chute doesn't open
what's going to happen is you're doing
you well why the hell what could happen
that the shoot would the chute wouldn't
open right so you do a thing and what
you do is your first jump you're
attached to a guy
who is going you know he's going to walk
you out so you go and you get there and
there's an airplane
and nobody's stopping everybody's still
going so you get onto the airplane and
you're sitting there and and you know
it's extra because you're sitting on
some dude's lap some stranger
he's sitting on his lap and it's like
you know you got trying to make small
talk yeah man
so you do you you'll be jumping with
people all the time huh
right you know
so and then you just want to make sure
you you have kids right you got people
you need to see right you just want to
make sure he's serious right so you get
in there so everything's normal so you
fly and you go up you go up you go up
you go up to 14 000 feet and you notice
there's a
light it's red and it's yellow and green
right so right now the light's red so
then you start thinking at some point
the light's going to go green because
you don't know what's going to happen
right and you wait and it goes yellow
and the light goes green and somebody
opens the door and in that moment you
realize you've never been in a freaking
airplane with the door open
right
terror no sorry i'm spitting
sorry
no terror terror terror terror right so
you go
and then
you know if you're if you were smart you
sat in the back so you don't go first
right and then people start going out of
the airplane
and you go and the guy
walks you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death
and they say on three and they say one
two and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three
right
right and you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one second
you realize
that it's the most blissful experience
of your life you're flying right it
doesn't feel like falling right it's
like the you actually are kind of held a
little bit by the wind and then you
start and you you start falling you're
falling and you there's zero fear you
realize that the point of maximum danger
is the point of minimum fear
it's bliss it's bliss and you're flying
right and you're doing it and then
20 seconds 25 seconds 40 seconds and you
have enough time to just kind of be like
oh
that's that building that's not like
that one
oh you can see the ocean
right you start doing all of that and
the the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before
why did you what do you need that fear
for
just don't go why are you scared in your
bed 16 hours before you jump why are you
scared in the car
why could you not enjoy breakfast
what did you need that the fear is
fear of what you're nowhere even near
the airplane everything up to
the stepping out there's actually no
reason to be scared it only just ruins
your day
you don't have to jump and then in that
moment all of a sudden where you should
be terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life and god placed
the best things in life on the other
side of terror on the other side of your
maximum fear are all of the best things
in life i have to show up at work with
the right attitude and with the positive
energy and uh i actually
uh had a t-shirt
made that said positive energy is a part
of your job description
right so the the idea that um i want to
show up with the right energy i want to
show up you know we're all here you know
even now we're all here we're trying to
feed our families we're we're trying to
have a good time we're trying you know
this is an important uh part of our
lives our time is all that we have so to
me it's hugely important to deliver
positive energy in a way because it's
vibrant so if
i come with positive energy then someone
else is going to pick up on the positive
energy and you're going to take it home
to your families and you know so for me
it's just hugely important to approach
everything and everybody at every turn
with the the most
positive loving kindness that i can
generate you know i've always been
really product oriented you know it's
like i want to win when i do something i
want to win i want it to be number one
and i want to smash it and i had a
period you know i have a daughter and i
was of a 15 year old daughter and she
really she got me and shifted
my focus from product to people it took
a couple of years but as soon as i got
knocked off of product and started
shifting to people the whole world
opened up for me again and acting opened
up in a whole
new way to not go into day one of a
movie trying to figure out what
everybody has to do so we win
versus opening up and every person is a
new
uh
it's a whole new world meaning the
characters you play or the people you
work with both absolutely you know
generally when i went into a product
when i went into a meeting with a
director my focus was can this guy win
can this girl win
and that it was a it was a you know it
was a pathology that got broken
for me a couple of years ago and then
releasing that and just wanting to
connect with people and wanting to grow
and wanting to get new ideas and have
new experiences that don't
have to have
uh
an outcome it just opened up a whole new
world for me and i fell in love and then
i couldn't imagine what else i could do
in acting that could add so much to my
life other than acting i look at the
world through a lens of comedy
right so
my natural reaction is always no matter
when something happens and i can't even
help it it's why is that funny you know
so even at a a funeral i can't help but
think why that's funny you know so it's
it's extremely helpful
for me just psychologically that no
matter what's going on i can't keep my
mind from finding jokes you know so it's
a it's a
a beautiful way to stay joyous and
positive do you get nervous or afraid
i i live in complete terror
but you know
everything for me about this business
and uh you know about what i've been
trying to build and what i've been
trying to do with my life keeps me in
terror i'm i am deeply
motivated by fear i'm surprised you say
you you live in fear how do you
deal with that do you turn to somebody
for advice do you
meditate what how do you get over that
you know i'm trying to to develop a more
realistic perspective
of what this business is yeah i told my
mother this the the other day she
thought it was hilarious i said when i
was 15 years old my first girlfriend
cheated on me oh
and i remember making a decision that
nobody would ever cheat on me again and
the way i was going to do that is by
being the biggest actor on earth huh
right so
is there's there's been this weird
psychology that i've always felt like if
my movies are number one my life is
going to work out great huh you know and
like oh that's you
i've always been um
the the type of person who uh
thought of i thought of myself as
resilient you know that i could always
make my way
back you got stuck
in the past you know and i think that
being stuck in the past is it it makes
it extremely difficult to to find your
way
out and
future thinking for me has always been
the way to get over difficult times to
be able to look over the darkness to a
potential time of light it's very rarely
do i look backwards i'm always
uh looking forward so both your kids are
in showbiz too
is that worrying for you or
no you know not it's
you know to me showbiz is not separated
from
the rules of the universe
right so
whether you're in
show business or
you know you're selling cars or
you're farming you know you're not
you're not separate from the laws of the
universe and all of the rules are the
same everywhere
so for you know for
from
my children the most important thing is
that they be encouraged to fully and
thoroughly be themselves
no matter what
and
when you when you have yourself and
you're thorough and confident in who you
are you can survive anywhere right goes
out to 190 countries um
hundreds of millions of people see it
but it's not in theaters so for two
artists what is the unique satisfaction
of this
you know so for me it's really
experimental what i learned uh when
independence day came out
so i was i've been doing the fresh
prince and that friday before
independence day came out everybody will
will will that monday was the first time
that anybody ever called me mr smith
right so there's something about that
big screen
that massive blockbuster that does
something
inside of people emotionally so i'm
curious as to see because netflix is
doing all of the other stuff absolutely
you know it's exactly the same
production process the promotion
everything is exactly the same you would
do for a gigantic blockbuster and the
question is
will
the
emotional resonance the sort of
nostalgic residue a year two years three
years from now
still be there with people not
experiencing it in the overwhelming
fashion of the cinema so you're just
this is an experiment and we'll see how
it works we'll see how it goes yeah but
it's definitely the future you know i
got the call from ridley and he said uh
he said i've got a gift for you
and uh he he sent me a concussion
and
uh you know i read it immediately
and i remember thinking uh that this
ain't no damn gift
i was like i'm a football dad yeah right
so you know
for for me it was a beautiful
screenplay but it opened up a huge
conflict for me did you know about about
what had happened before did you know
the story a little bit of vaguely okay
really vaguely i i knew
uh you know my son played football for
for four years
um and during that time i had never
heard
uh about the the concussion issue okay
at all at all okay so you know
it was part of what really uh inspired
me and made me want to to
to do the the film forced me to to have
to to do the film is because as a parent
i had no idea right i had no idea that
there was a
an issue with repetitive head trauma
right right in in football you know so
it was a uh it was a
quite a revelation a personal
confrontation with death
made me see the value of time and the
fact that the
only elixir is love
you know so the the the time that you
spend has got to be in preparing
yourself and giving and receiving
uh the most amount of love you can you
know my mission is to improve lives
so i want to do things
that put positivity
and
positive energy and love into the world
i'm going to put on this uh orc mask
because i can't walk the floor at comic
con
as me
i'm out in the middle with everybody i
think i'm with people
all right so now
i feel sorry for joel
only all these things but if we go out
in public i'm gonna kill somebody so
let's go
and i never get to do this this is gonna
be great i'm gonna get to walk around
it's hard to see and it's hard to
breathe but i'm a soldier so i don't
need neither one of them thing i'm gonna
bark i'm gonna park
uh
and i'm curious if it lets you i think
the obvious answer is yes but like
you're expressing your own ideas and
thoughts more often than if you're being
directed yes absolutely and and because
it's um it's not really uh
directed per se it's a you know it's
you know sort of half capturing real
life um
uh
i i shoot everything now uh so what i
find is
it makes me
explore and experience in ways that i
wouldn't have if i wasn't going to shoot
it right you know we get into cities you
know we we get into you know seoul
uh korea and i'm exhausted uh but i know
mlma is doing
something so i want to you know when it
go now it actually makes me get out of
the bed and go and explore and
experience and and meet people you know
even this time with you and doing this
press conference at the youtube space
it's like um it's an opportunity i
wanted to meet with you i wanted to sit
with you i wanted to hear what
you think it's like it jogs
uh that creative beast in inside of me i
went to
a
catholic school
uh up to
eighth grade with
uh
all white kids and probably two or three
black kids
but you know predominantly white school
and then i went to my neighborhood high
school in ninth grade that was 99
black kids
um so the first day that i walk in
to
ninth grade
i walked into the lunchroom
and you know it's like 500 kids and
for to this day i don't know why i did
this i'm sure it was because i was i was
nervous
and you know i got i have a thing with
fear i don't like being scared so i'm
sure i was i walked in uh i looked
around
and i said excuse me can i have your
attention can i have your attention
please he's here
he's here right now thank you thank you
the people was kind of looking and there
was this one dude and he was sitting
there
and he looked up to me he said man don't
nobody get that you hear
right and i said hey just give me ten
minutes your girl gonna care
right and he was like
all right and you got to watch that nod
that nod is not a good nod he was like
and i was like okay so i went so i'm
walking up the steps we're out of the
lunchroom and i forgot about it so we're
going and i'm walking up the steps and
he had taken one of those combination
locks
and he put the lock in the palm of his
hand and put his put the uh the loop
around his knuckle and he was holding
the lock in his hand
and
as i was walking up the steps he cracked
me
in the side of my head
with the lock
and i went down i was out i don't
remember nothing i still got the lump on
my head you can't see it cause i got my
hair but i still like there's still a
lump
so i remember i fell down i hit my mouth
on the steps
all of that stuff
you know so i went up so i'm in the
principal's office all of that the
police come and i got the ice on my lips
and i'm i'm sitting
in the principal's office
and my father comes in he sees me and
and you know i'm telling the story now
the police are there
and
i remember i saw this kid
they put him in handcuffs
and took him out of the school
and i'm looking sitting in the
principal's office and i'm watching the
police take him out and put him in the
back of a police car
and
[Music]
i just couldn't believe it had escalated
to
a kid being removed from from school
and
i was laying in my bed that night and i
was just feeling like
and i had the recognition
that i had caused this kid to
throw his life away
right
and he was kicked out of school and i
never knew what what happened to him but
i i have a sense that it didn't go well
beyond there and i felt a deep
sense of
regret and a deep sense that i had
caused an emotion in a person that made
them do that
and
that that feeling of regret
turned into
a sort of a fear of how much power i had
and i was like
everything i say and do has that kind of
effect
on other human beings
and in that moment
i decided that i would never walk into a
room and do anything other than inspire
and uplift and enlighten people
and help people
to
be the greater versions of themselves
and i would never do anything
that would cause people
to
to rile up the darkest dirtiest parts of
people i only wanted to enliven and
enlighten and inspire and i remember
laying in my bed
that night and i made that promise to
myself and i made that promise to god
and it's something that has completely
shaped how i approach people how i
approach moments how i walk into rooms
how i deal with every human being on
this earth i was just uh having a debate
with a friend of mine and we got stuck
on the difference between fault and
responsibility she kept talking about
how something was somebody's fault it's
somebody's fault and i was like it
really it don't matter whose fault it is
that something is broken if it's your
responsibility to fix it for example is
it's not somebody's fault if their
father was an abusive alcoholic but it's
for damn sure their responsibility
to figure out how they're going to deal
with those traumas and try to make a
life out of it it's not your fault if
your partner cheated and ruined your
marriage but it is for damn sure your
responsibility to figure out how to take
that pain and how to overcome that and
build a happy life for yourself fault
and responsibility do not go together it
sucks but they don't when something is
somebody's fault we want them to suffer
we want them punished we want them to to
pay and we want it to be their
responsibility to fix it but
that's that's not how it works
especially when it's your heart
your heart
your life your happiness is your
responsibility and your responsibility
alone as long as we're pointing the
finger
and and and stuck in whose fault
something is
we're jammed and trapped into victim
mode when you're in victim mode you are
stuck in suffering the road to power is
in taking responsibility
your heart
your life your happiness is your
responsibility and your responsibility
alone all right here's what's going to
happen twitch is going to ask us each to
name three things of
three types of like cars or something
and we'll have five seconds to name
three things and then hit that to see
how much time is left on the clock okay
all right if you do it you get a point
if time runs out you get no points at
all five seconds goes very very fast
okay i shall go first you shall go first
okay okay ellen name three things you do
in a car uh you drive you park and you
uh
say hello to people
[Laughter]
you do when you're waiting
when you're driving have you ever lived
in a small town you do you raise your
food
all right all right okay let's see i see
now we need some like judges or
something
you drive you you say hi you wink you
win
okay will will name three things you
should never do in a car never uh
uh drink uh smoke
make love that's not true that's not
true
[Applause]
but you shouldn't do it i mean yeah you
should do it at home
[Laughter]
i see it's hard it is hard
okay ellen tell us three words you use a
lot uh love
uh baby and uh
[Applause]
be kind i'm gonna give you that one
because that's the right answer yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we'll name your three favorite
songs to sing in the shower in the
shower uh the the the dream girls uh
i'm telling you um whitney houston's uh
oh darn
yeah but that's uh it's like the end i
am telling you
i'm not going
you're the best man i've
[Applause]
[Applause]
he was always challenged for that right
like all your saw if you're a different
rapper your positivity was always
challenged like yeah you always wanted
you to justify being popular
right absolutely yeah no that was a that
was a uh
a
difficult
time coming up because it's it's like
i'm from i'm from philly right so during
that time in philly it was joe frazier
and rocky so a fist fight was common so
you grew up
right you grew up
d used to he called it pug city
he's like pug city he's like he's like
chuck was like damn you can't go to
philly without getting in a fight right
so it's like i grew up in that so for me
to
uh it was always difficult for people
you know to say i was soft and i was you
know my my my music was cotton candy and
all of that so i i always
wanted to fight to try to to to prove
myself but the be
fighting yourself to maintain positivity
is the hardest fight you ever gonna have
right and it's like that struggle to
just stay my course to you know
be the person in the world that that i
wanted to be no matter what people said
and it was uh
uh
i started to call it offensive
positivity
right like you know i wasn't gonna be on
defense with my positivity i was going
to be on offense with it me and jeff had
come out with our smash hit parents just
don't understand we made a bunch of
money we won a grammy album with triple
platinum i had motorcycles and cars i
called the gucci store in atlanta and i
was like hey will y'all close it down if
i bring my friends
and i'm smiling but that's stupid we
released our next album and it was like
a flop
it was a tragedy it went like
double plastic
i had spent
most of my money like all of i spent all
my money
and
i didn't forget
but
i didn't pay the irs
in my mind i mean i wasn't like
trying to avoid paying taxes i was just
like
oh damn they need their money
the irs took off took all that stuff so
i was like broke broke broke being
famous and broke is a shitty combination
because you're still famous and people
recognize you but they recognize you
while you sit next to them on the bus
and the stuff they ask you to sign on a
bus you know like oh can you sign my
baby that's a sharpie i probably
shouldn't just writing on the baby with
that are you too big to sign my baby
well no i mean
you know so i signed it
so i was like laying around
and
my girlfriend was like dude we're not
doing this like you're not just gonna be
laying around this house all day you
gonna go do something i was like what
what i'm supposed to do go where people
is is doing it where are people doing it
go to the arsenal hall show just go
stand around at the arsenio hall show
yes that's stupid
so i went to the art center hall show
and
i met a dude named benny medina benny
medina is the real life fresh prince of
bel air except he actually went from
watts to beverly hills same basic
concept way shorter distance i meet
benny and he pitches me the idea for
this show and i'm like you know i'm not
an actor i'm like cool and he said hey
you know i want you to meet quincy jones
quincy jones is producing with me
so i find myself at quincy's and there's
actors and artists and celebrities and
politicians like everybody's at quincy's
house it's like the wiz without the
costumes so benny walks me in and
introduced me to clinton hey q what's up
man you say hey man you know i saw your
music videos i love i love what you're
doing i love what you're doing tell me
rap name again they call me the fresh
prince all right good that's what we're
gonna call the show and he handed me a
screenplay for a failed morris day pilot
like i don't have the time so i need you
to do this i need to go ahead take a few
minutes take ten minutes study the
script and i'm gonna clear all the stuff
out the living room and we're gonna have
everybody sit down in the living room
we're gonna do an audition he had movers
that could reset his furniture i was
like this dude is real so it goes out
tells everybody come on come on come on
and i was like you hold up man hold up
i'm not ready to do no audition and he
said oh all right all right uh well what
you need tell me what you need just set
the meeting for a week and i could do it
he said yeah yeah you know brandon
tartakov the head of nbc is out there
i'll get him to schedule for next week
and then you know what's gonna happen
something's gonna come up and then he's
gonna have to reschedule oh yeah yeah so
three so three weeks from now we can do
it three weeks from now i said yeah yeah
yeah three weeks from now be good or you
can take 10 minutes right now and you
can change your life forever i was like
[ __ ] it then
yes give me 10 minutes i said yes and i
let it rip and i got to the end and
everybody is clapping quincy looks at
brandon tardikov the head of nbc did you
like it and brandon said yeah yeah i
liked the questions he says no did you
like it and he's like yeah i liked it he
was like good you're his lawyer draw me
up something right now
rejection is everywhere you know we all
deal with the the you don't anymore
yeah me worst of all me worst of all you
know i think the the idea
of
rejection
is
relative i mean if you you take a you
know a kid in
a small town
and somebody posts something negative
about them
and all of their friends laugh you know
that's
the worst rejection a human being can
experience it's not you know for that
kid it's not any less than for my kids
who read it on a comment page you know
it's it's emotionally it's it's the same
my kids grew up in this world so they're
much more acclimated to
the difficulties of this world but it
doesn't make it uh emotionally
um
uh
more difficult or more painful than for
any other child who has to deal with it
[Music]
you know growing up my mother and father
and grandmother demanded no less of me
than to represent the family every time
i stepped out in a way that was helpful
to others the city
gave him his
start
he's worked hard and the city has
worked hard for him knowing that this
man is from west philly opens eyes for
them they opens their lens when you're
in philadelphia you see a lot of things
in the youth in the neighborhood that
not always positive and i think
seeing that will motivate you all in
this home because you're always going to
want something better for yourself you
don't have enough role models out here
you got too many kids being led astray
thinking the wrong things is what's good
they grow up too fast you need people
that's putting that out there like you
don't have to do this you don't have to
do that it's so much easier being
yourself when you
are a young kid and you walk into school
and you see images like this it makes
you aspire to want to be that person
right
what he's done in his life have vibrated
all overseas to touch you and touch
people yeah around the world but this
right here will affect people the main
thing you did let me tell you the main
detail yeah you got will's ears right
this man who is an icon
is looking at gla so my kids every day
will see this image and know that you
can be whatever you want to be this is a
man who grew up in philadelphia went to
overbrook high school up the street was
a part of this world that he
now is looking at us and telling my
children you can be whatever you want to
be
that's it's just so powerful
if you're a kid here growing up now
and you see this every day
it can give you a real understanding
that
this guy
is me
you know he lived here he grew up here
he had the same
chances as me the same possibilities as
me the same
everything
and
he's being painted on a wall because
he's
done something incredible with his life
we're about to make history we're doing
an ig live to the international
space station
oh yeah and see now that's the thing
look i'm doing it like that
everybody can't do an interview to the
international space station and house
you in terms of like the the simple
basics right so you on earth
people have to poop you're like it's
important to poop on earth right so when
you're up there i see your microphone
floating i need to understand what you
do with that like how do you manage that
well are you sure you want to talk about
this i have this problem because it is
pretty challenging
i like to say you can have a good day in
the bathroom and you can have a really
bad day in the bathroom and you really
you hope for the good days but bad days
can be challenging
on earth we talk about the the you know
the mile high club has anyone you know
attempted for research purposes has
anyone attempted you know the process of
procreating the human species uh in
space all right well similar to the last
question i'll just say are you sure we
want to talk about this on the interview
i'm just you know i i'm a man of the
people drew i'm a man of the people and
it's important to me to ask the
questions that the people want the
answers to i'll just say as far as i
know i have no knowledge of those tests
being done but i can imagine that that
would present some unique opportunities
i enjoy
um
connecting
with with people and and ideas and
you know it's
i have a mission statement so every year
for probably the past 10 years i've
worked out a mission statement for
myself and for the last few few years
the mission statement has stayed the
same and it you know it's been improved
lives
right so
when when i go into something i'm
looking for
how
the quality of this piece could
potentially improve lives but it's all
along the way it's when you make the
movie and how you're interacting with
people in the process and you know the
the concept of improving lives runs
through the center of everything i do
and then i realized that the the the way
to improve lives is to continually
improve yourself right so with that
every every morning when i when i get
out of the bed you know i
i haven't fixed everything in the world
yet so there's always something to do
and uh in this film i read an
interesting quote um
for the uh siddhartha
gautama the buddha he said
that
good people have to get out of the bed
every day and try to empty the ocean
with a ladle
right
and i thought that was you know i knew
that was profound and i paused for a
second and i said all right what the
hell is a ladle right
right so that you know i just i touched
it on my ipad it's ladle oh it's like a
big spoon a big spoon okay
it's like a soup spoon yeah it's like a
soup spoon i was like why are you soup
smooth so try to empty the ocean with a
soup spoon you know as the the mentality
of how you you wake up every day to try
to do good
in the world so for me i'm i'm uh i'm
really driven by continually trying to
elevate my elevate my mind and elevate
my spirit and care for my body and um to
be able to love as many people as
effectively as as possible with this
mystery of life that i've been given
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to develop a reliable
work ethic check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there hard work working a little bit
harder work ethic very hard working go
hard work ethic work work
ethic